well we've done a lot of work with with
how fast something moves let's see if we
can work with how fast something spins
so let's see what we can do let me let
me since we're going to be working with
things spinning let me draw a circle
since things that's been going circles
so there is my circle and then let me
just draw the positive x-axis because
it'll come handy in a second okay that's
the positive x-axis and let's say that I
have an object and this circle is the
objects path so let's say this is the
object and it's going around in a circle
in counter clockwise direction it's not
squiggly kind of Christ just going
around this way and let's say I wanted
to figure out or I wanted to quantify
how much or how fast this thing is
spinning so one thing that you've you're
probably familiar with is you know
revolutions per second or rotations per
second so so let's write that down let's
just say let's just say for the sake of
argument that this was moving at I don't
know one revolution per second so after
one second it goes back in another
second so that's how fast it's spinning
one revolution per second one revolution
I'll put just Rev per second so let's
see if we can quantify that in angles
and we'll do it in radians but you could
always convert it back to degrees if you
want so let me know if you can see that
line but let's let's just say that theta
is the angle between the radius from the
center to that object and the positive
x-axis so this is Theta so if this
object is traveling at one revolution
per second how many radians per second
is it traveling well how many radians
are there in a revolution well there's
two pi radians in a revolution right
what one go around in a circle is 2 pi
radians so we could we could say x so
this equals one Rev per second times 2
pi radians per Rev right and then you
the revolutions will cancel out and
you have one times two pi so you have
two pi radians per second so this equals
two pi radians per second that's
interesting I could we now know exactly
you know after five seconds how many
radians has it gone or after half a
second how many radians has gone but
that's that might be vaguely used so
let's see if we can somehow convert from
this notion of how fast something is
spinning to its actual to its actual
speed I was tempted to say a velocity
but its velocity is always changing
right because the direction is always
changing but the magnitude of the door
of the velocity is staying the same so
it's beat is staying the same but well
we'll say v4 speed because that's what
they tend to do and most formulas that
you you'll see so let's think about it
this way in in one revolution so there's
a couple of ways we can think about this
but as we go in in as we go one
revolution how far has this object
traveled well it's traveled their
circumference of this of this circle and
in order to circumference we have to
know the radius of the circle so let's
say that the radius is R let's say it's
in meters are meters so how many how
many how many meters will I travel in
one second then well it you could you
could do the same thing up here one
revolution per second times two PI R
where R is the radius
whoops two PI R you can ignore that line
meters per revolution right that's just
a circumference of the thing of the
circle and that equals the revolutions
cancel out two PI R two PI R meters per
second so that's interesting we given
the radius and how many revolutions per
second we can now figure out its
velocity so this right here is its is
how fast it's spinning and this is the
object's actual speed right and this
term of how fast something spinning
that's called angular
velocity and of course you know the the
term for how fast something is actually
moving is velocity so and and and just
so you know the term for angular
velocity is this this curvy w I think
that's lowercase Omega but that little
curl that's angular velocity right so in
this case angular velocity is equal to 2
pi radians per second and what's the
velocity equal to or at least the
magnitude of the velocity I know the
direction is always changing well we
know that the velocity is equal to 2 pi
are meters per second so if we just
ignore the units for a second what do
you see the difference between the
angular velocity in the velocity the
angular velocity in this case is 2 pi
and the velocity is 2 pi R so in general
if you just multiply the angular
velocity times R you get the velocity so
angular velocity times the radius is
equal to the velocity or you can divide
both sides of that by r you get the
angular velocity is equal to the
velocity divided by the radius and this
is a formula that you should know by
heart although it's good to kind of know
where it came from and another way I
guess even a I did it this way to maybe
give you an intuition because I always
have to work with numbers especially
when I'm new to a concept so that's why
I said one revolution per second stead
of just putting everything as a variable
but another way to to really to think
about is is what is the definition of a
Radian by definition a Radian if if this
is if this angle is X radians is X
radians its what it's an angle and it
also tells us that the arc that is that
is that is kind of projected by this
angle is equal to X radius this is
radiuses so if we if each radius is 2
meters it would be x times 2 meters so
if this is X radians and this is going
to be x times our meters and that
actually comes from the definition the
definition of the
of the Radian and that might that might
be more intuitive to you than the
original exhibition or less so hopefully
one of those two works but as you can
see if this angle is X and this is and
this distance is X times R and if Omega
is change in that angle over change in
time that's omega that says Omega like
this Omega then we know this is true to
that velocity is just changing this over
change in time right velocity is change
in the radius doesn't change change in X
times R divided by change in time and we
know once again that this is Omega so
kind of another way we just showed again
that Omega times the radius is equal to
the velocity or the angular velocity
times the radius is equal to the
velocity and this is a thing to learn
we'll see in a couple of things will you
know when I do the proof for centripetal
acceleration in calculus I'm going to
use this fact and when I actually I'm
probably gonna record that video now I'm
actually going to show you the law of
conservation of angular momentum which
is very similar to the law of
conservation of momentum but it deals
with things spinning and this is going
to this notion of angular velocity is
going to come in useful so this is the
important takeaway the W equals V over R
and hopefully my video has not confused
you and has shown you that W the rate at
which the angle is changing is equal to
the velocity of the object or the
magnitude of the velocity divided by the
radius around of the circle that it's
it's spinning I'll see you in the next
video